IT'S A LOT FUNNIER THAN HIS
MONOLOGUES, WHICH ARE NOT FUNNY
AT ALL, ACTUALLY.
AS THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY LURCHES
FARTHER AND FARTHER TO THE LEFT,
THE PARTY IS LOSING THE BASIC
WILLPOWER NEEDED TO PROJECT
CIVILIZED LIVING.
GARBAGE IS PILING UP IN
DEMOCRATIC CITIES AS MUNICIPAL
GOVERNMENT NO LONGER CARES LONG
ENOUGH TO KEEP THEIR CITIES
CLEAN.
SO CONSERVATIVE ACTIVISTS ARE
STEPPING UP.
HE IS ORGANIZED MAJOR CLEANUPS
IN SEVERAL CITIES, MOST
RECENTLY, HIS GROUP OF
VOLUNTEERS REMOVED TRASH IN
CHICAGO AND AUSTIN, TEXAS.
SCOTT JOINS US NOW.
YOU STARTED THIS AFTER SOMEONE
QUITE INCREDIBLY IN THE
21ST CENTURY DEVELOPED A
FLESH-EATING DISEASE.
HE CAUGHT A FLESH-EATING DISEASE
JUST FROM WATCHING THROUGH THE
STREETS OF LOS ANGELES.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
WHEN WE WENT INTO LOS ANGELES, I
WAS ADAMANT THAT EVERY SINGLE
VOLUNTEER WHERE A HAZMAT SUIT.
SO WHEN WE PICKED UP 50 TONS OF
TRASH, WE HAD BOOTIES, GLOVES,
HAZMAT SUITS ON TO PICK UP TRASH
IN L.A.
>> Mark: THAT IS AMAZING THAT
IT IS ACTUALLY NOT SAFE TO WALK
AROUND WITHOUT A HAZMAT SUIT.
THESE ARE THE GUYS, BY THE WAY,
WHO KEEP TELLING US THAT THEY
ARE SAVING THE PLANET, BUT CAN'T
ACTUALLY KEEP THEIR OWN STREETS
CLEAN.
>> I THINK THE DIFFERENCE IS, I
AM A CONSERVATIVE ACTIVIST.
I'M A BLEEDING HEART
CONSERVATIVE, THAT INSTEAD OF
POINTING MY FINGER AT PEOPLE AND
SAYING, HOW DARE YOU, I DARE TO
GO OUT WITH VOLUNTEERS AND PICK
UP TRASH.
>> Mark: LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT
THE POLITICS OF THAT.
ALL OF THESE CITIES HAVE BEEN
DEMOCRAT RUN FOR DECADES.
AND THEY ARE FILTHY.
IF YOU KNEW CALIFORNIA CITIES
HALF A CENTURY AGO, YOU WOULD
THINK THAT THEY HAD BEEN NUKED
OR THEY HAD BEEN BOMBED OR
SOMETHING TERRIBLE, SOME
TERRIBLE CATASTROPHE HAD
BEFALLEN THEM.
AND THE POLITICS OF IT WOULD
SEEM TO SUGGEST THAT YOU JUST
SAY, OKAY, LET'S LEAVE IT TO
THESE DEMOCRATS TO RUN THEIR
CITIES INTO THE GROUND, AND THEN
PEOPLE WILL GET THE MESSAGE.
WHY DO YOU PREFER TO ACTUALLY
ACT AND CLEAN UP THESE DUMPS?
>> MY STATEMENT, BY GOING INTO
DEMOCRAT RUN CITIES IS OVERTLY
POLITICAL.
I DON'T HAVE TO GO IN AS A
REPUBLICAN OR A TRUMP SUPPORTER.
SIMPLY THE FACT THAT I COME AS A
VIRGINIAN, HAD TO GO INTO
BALTIMORE, LOS ANGELES, CHICAGO,
AUSTIN, I'M MAKING A POLITICAL
STATEMENT HERE BUT I'M NOT
POINTING TO
POINTING THE FINGER.
MY MOTTO IS STOP TALKING, START
DOING.
I'M WAITING WITH LOVE, AND
SHOWING THAT REPUBLICANS DO CARE
ABOUT THE ENVIRONMENT.
ALL WE WANT IS TO MAKE AMERICA A
CLEANER, GREENER PLACE.
>> Mark: WHAT WAS CHICAGO
LIKE?
TO MOST NONCHICAGOANS, THAT IS
THE PLACE OF GREAT DANGER.
YOU HAD HUNDREDS OF VOLUNTEERS
OUT WITH YOU ON THE STREETS OF
CHICAGO.
>> THAT IS RIGHT AND THE MOST
DANGEROUS CITY, AND I SAY THAT
WITH QUOTATIONS, WE HAD 250
VOLUNTEERS COME ALL FROM
TWITTER, FACEBOOK, INSTAGRAM,
THAT WERE ON 63RD STREET, AND I
WANT TO GIVE A SHOUT OUT TO
PASTOR CORY BROOKS, WHO OPENED
PROJECT HOOD AND HIS DOORS TO US
IN CHICAGO.
>> Mark: IN AUSTIN YOU ALSO
GOT SOME PRAISE FROM THE
GOVERNOR.
HE FOUND HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS
OF NEEDLES, PRESUMABLY THEY
COULD JUST BE LYING AROUND, ALL
TERRIBLE THINGS COULD HAPPEN
THERE.
THE GOVERNOR ACTUALLY THANKED
YOU FOR WHAT YOU DID.
>> GOVERNOR GREG ABBOTT HAS DONE
A GREAT JOB ACTUALLY GOING INTO
THE CITY OF AUSTIN AND HELPING
CLEAN UP.
AND THE SPOT THAT WE CLEANED UP
OVER AND UNDER PASSING UNDER
I.E. 83, A HOMELESS CAMP, THE
GOVERNOR ACTUALLY SENT A CLEANUP
CREW TO GO UNDER THERE.
HE IS DOING A WONDERFUL JOB,
EVEN THOUGH THE MAYOR OF AUSTIN
ISN'T DOING HIS WORK.
>> Mark: WHAT IS THE REASON
THAT THE CITY OF AUSTIN, THE
CITY OF CHICAGO, THE CITY OF
SAN FRANCISCO, WHAT IS THE
REASON THAT THEY ACTUALLY
CAN'T -- THAT IS JUST GARBAGE
COLLECTION.
THAT IS JUST BASIC, A MUNICIPAL
FUNCTION OF GOVERNMENT.
WHAT IS THE REASON THEY CAN'T DO
IT?
>> IT'S ALL POLITICS, MARK.
WHEN WE APPLIED FOR DUMPSTERS
FOR THE CITY OF BALTIMORE, THE
FIRST TIME, WE WERE DENIED
PERMITS.
IT DENIED.
AND THAT DOESN'T TELL ME
ANYTHING ELSE EXCEPT FOR ITS
POLITICALLY MOTIVATED, TO STOP A
CONSERVATIVE FROM COMING INTO
PICK UP TRASH, SO WE DID IT
ANYWAY.
TO STOP TALKING, START DOING.